Hallo, guten Abend. Mein Name ist Enes, ich bin der Sousi des zuständigen Art in dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen ein anderes Gespräch durchführen.
Der vor wir anfangen, muss ich Ihre persönlichen Daten aufnehmen.
Ist das Wortung für Sie?
Ja, gerne, natürlich. Aber wie ist Ihr Name wieder nochmal?
Mein Name ist Enes.
Enes, was ist mein Name?
Entschuldigung, nochmal bitte.
Woher kommt der Name?
Ich komme aus der ZUKAY.
Das bedeutet Jungspeck.
Okay, okay, alles klar.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Maria Putzel.
Maria Putzel.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vorunachnahmen buchstabieren?
Maria, ganz normal, Maria.
Martha, Antonin, Hans, Ida, Anton.
Nachname?
Perzell, Paula, Öl, Pheodor, Deppelin, Emi, Ludwig.
Okay, Putzel.
Frau Putzel, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 38 Jahre alt.
38 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau gebaut?
23. Februar 1987.
Okay.
Wie alt und wie groß und wie viel, wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin circa 72 Kilo.
Und ich bin 1 Meter 68.
Okay.
Was führt Sie zu uns?
Was kann ich mit Ihnen tun?
Herr Doktor, also ich habe seit drei Tagen
die stunehmende Starkeschmerzen im Unterbauch,
so auf der linken Seite.
Okay, seit drei Tagen haben Sie Starkeschmerzen
in der linken Seite und Unterbauch in der linken Seite.
Ja.
Okay, können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie ehe, stichend, birenend oder drücken?
Das ist sehr schwierig, es ist halt da,
es wird manchmal wellenartig.
Und manchmal sticht es auch so Richtung Leiste.
Und man melden mal weniger.
Wellenartig und stichend, haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Wie sind Sie diese Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Oder wir haben diese Schmerzen begonnen, plötzlich oder langsam?
Sie sind ganz plötzlich aufgetreten, natürlich hat er es mal gar nichts.
Und dann sind Sie plötzlich aufgetreten und immer stärker geworden.
Immer stärker geworden.
Ja.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen,
oder wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
1 bedeutet sehr leicht, 10 bedeutet unerträgliche Schmerzen.
Am Anfang waren Sie wenig, aber jetzt sind Sie mehr geworden.
Ich würde sagen, jetzt sind Sie ungefähr bei so 6 oder 7.
6 oder 7.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder verübergreinbar?
Also es ist immer da, aber es wird mal mehr, mal weniger.
Okay.
Haben Sie etwas, haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen etwas eingenommen?
Also am Anfang nicht, aber danach habe ich ein bisschen Paracetamol genommen.
Es ist etwas besser geworden, aber ganz weg ist es nicht mehr.
Okay.
Wie viel Milligramm haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, Paracetamol.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Tabletten genommen, heute Morgen und eine jetzt vorhin.
Okay.
Schöteralen die Schmerzen, ihr ging vorhin aus?
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe das Gefühl, dass Strahl so ein bisschen in die Leiste aus.
In die Leiste.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen über?
Ganz leicht.
Haben Sie Erbrewschen?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen, zum Beispiel Essen, Trinken, Bewegung usw?
Also wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich laufe, dann wird es besser, das stimmt.
Verschlechtet, oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie unter ähnliche Beschwerden schon einmal gelitten?
Ja, das ist das erste Mal.
Erstmal.
Okay.
Und fühle dich füge ich?
Nein, ich würde es nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe mich jetzt bisher nicht mehr.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kalten Schweiß bemerkt oder leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit zugenommen oder abgenommen?
Nein, nein, nein, das ist auch alles gleich.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindel habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Ich würde Sie fragen, treten beim Wasserlassen oder beim Stuhlgang?
Schwierigkeiten auf?
Also ich habe das Gefühl, wenn ich Wasser lasse oder zum Stuhlgang gehe,
dass die Schmerzen schlimmer werden.
Schmerzhaft.
Ja, also beim Wasserlassen oder insbesondere beim Stuhlgang,
wenn ich etwas pressen muss, dann habe ich das Gefühl,
dass es noch schlimmer wird.
Okay.
Haben Sie durchfällig oder verheiratet Stoffung?
Nein.
Und wie sieht Ihre Öl aus?
Wie immer, da ist verabendlich, da habe ich nichts Besonderes gemerkt.
Und wie sieht Ihre Stuhl aus?
Das ist auch normal, ich habe nichts Besonderes gefallen.
Nicht besonders, okay.
Mussten Sie häufiger Wasserlassen als gewünscht?
Nein, nein.
Stuhlgang?
Ach, okay.
Okay.
Fällt Ihnen in diesem Summonhunk noch etwas ein,
dass mir das wichtig sein könnte?
Also ich will einfach nur, dass Sie herausfinden,
was das ist, weil das wird immer schlimmer.
Und es wird sehr unangenehm.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Blut in Ihrem Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein.
Nein, das ist normal.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also da bin ich regelmäßig beim Hausarzt,
ich habe sehr kontrolliert, immer die Impfungen,
bisher war alles in Ordnung.
Super.
Okay.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Eigentlich nicht so, nein.
Ich bin sehr unsportlich.
Und wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Eigentlich ganz gut.
Ganz gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Nein.
Das ist aber alles in Ordnung.
Okay, gut.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverkehrlichkeiten bekannt?
Also ich habe Allergien gegen Polen,
Verschiedens der Blüten.
Und ich habe eine Laktose Unverträglichkeit.
Und wie äußert sich die Allergien?
Womit äußert sich Allergien?
Im Frühjahr läuft halt meine Nase, die Augen brennen,
ich muss öfter niesen.
Und wenn ich dann die Zitri ziehen nehme,
dann geht es eigentlich ganz gut.
Bei Bedarf nehmen Sie die Zitri ziehen.
Ja, genau.
Frau Pützl, rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ab und zu mal, ja.
Aber nicht so.
Wie viel trinken Sie Alkohol?
Das ist ein Gläschenbein.
Sehr gut.
Darf ich Sie fragen, ob Sie Kontakt mit Drogen haben?
Mit Drogen? Nein, damit haben wir nichts zu tun.
Nein, gut.
Okay, leiden Sie, ich würde Sie nun nach Ihrer Vorgeschichte fragen.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen,
wie zum Beispiel Blutdruck, Sköpfrankheit.
Ich habe einen hohen Blutdruck seit ein, zwei Jahren.
Nicht mehr mit dem Vent, aber damit ist es gar nicht ganz gut eingestellt.
Seit zwei Jahren leiden Sie uns an Blutdruck
und dagegen nehmen Sie Medikamente?
Ja.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Kandesatan, 4 Milligramm.
Kandesatan.
Einmal?
Ja, einmal.
Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Nein, wirklich, ich weiß es noch nicht.
Okay.
Würden Sie schon einmal operieren?
Nein.
Okay.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben noch, die geht es gut.
Mein Vater hat noch seinen Prostata-Leiden,
musste auch mal operiert worden, aber was ist genau,
ich weiß es nicht.
Okay.
Prostata operiert worden.
Ist Ihre Mutter gesund?
Ja.
Also, er ist ein hohen Alters,
kann in der Mitte, kann in der Platte.
Gab es Fehler von Krebs in der Familie?
Nein.
Ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Okay, ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, habe ich schon gesagt, Kandesatan.
Kandesatan, und gibt es noch andere Medikamente?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Friseurin.
Friseurin.
Arbeiten Sie im Moment?
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie Probleme auf Ihren Arbeit,
die Belastung?
Nein, das ist alles gut.
Arbeit macht mir Spaß, das ist alles in Ordnung.
Sind Sie heiraten?
Ja, und ich habe zwei kleine Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja.
Lieben Sie mit Ihrem Mann, oder?
Ja, wir wohnen mit meinen Mann, mit den Kindern zusammen.
Okay, Frau.
Ich glaube,
wollen Sie unsere Kinder machen, Herr Doktor?
Ja, na, na, na.
Nee, bist du da hin?
Ja, ich habe alle wichtigen Informationen gesammelt.
Haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, das muss mir helfen, Herr Doktor.
Was ist das?
Wollen Sie mich noch untersuchen?
Ja, natürlich.
Nun würde ich Sie über weitere Schiffe informieren.
Also, wegen Ihrem Beschwerden sollten Sie bei uns bleiben.
Und in dieser Zeit möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen
und dann Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Und ich möchte Röntgenaufnahme des Baus
verlassen.
Und danach je nach Befunds möchte ich
Ultraschall durchführen.
Und am Ende besprechen wir
wieder über Ihre Beschwerden.
Und dann kann ich Ihnen sagen, worunter Sie leisen.
Das hört sich schon mal ganz gut ein.
Sie machen auch Ultraschall.
Vielen Dank.
Dann machen Sie mal los, bevor das Ganze schlimmer wird.
Dankeschön.
Herr Kollegen, andere Fragen?
Ja, Frau Fözel, ist Ihre Monatsblutung regeln?
Ja, bisher hatte ich keine Probleme.
Die sollte eigentlich so in 2 Wochen bekommen.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Könnte es sein, dass Sie so leicht warnen?
An Sicht normal weiß ich nicht.
Keine Fragen?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie eine Schwellung oder
eine Farbeveränderung in der Haut?
Farbeveränderung in der Haut, in leistendem Bemmel?
Nein, ich bin nicht aufgefallen. Ich habe es Gefühl, dass mein Bauch insgesamt ein bisschen gebläht ist, aber ansonsten,
so eine Auffälligkeit ist mir der nicht, ich habe mich nicht bemerkt.
Danke schön.
Ich denke für die finanzielle Diagnose, aber diese ist eine Frage,
sind Sie nicht mehr vom Ausgang an einen anderen Ort gewandert?
Nein, war nur die gleiche Regierung.
Frau Putzel, waren Sie schon einmal im Krankenhaus geblieben?
Nein.
Ich will auch dieses Mal nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Muss sie kapriert werden, Herr Doktor?
Nein, habe ich mich gefragt, dass früher haben Sie schon bei Ihnen etwas durchgeführt?
Nein, glücklicherweise noch nicht.
Danke schön.
Frau Putzel, haben Sie Ausfluss bemerkt, original Ausfluss?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Ist alles ausgerucht.
Wurden Sie mal operiert?
Nein.
Noch eine Frage.
Wann war die
Ausfluss bemerkt?
Guten Tag, Herr Obark.
Guten Tag lieber NS, hallo.
Mein Name ist NS und wenn Sie Zeit hätten, würde ich gerne einen neuen Patient vorstellen?
Gerne NS, ich weiß wie du bist, ich weiß, dass du NS heißt, du brauchst dich nicht noch mal vorzustellen.
Weil du bist neu und immer sehr freundlich, erzähl mal, was hast du für einen Patient?
Ich bin Maria Putzel, 38 Jahre alt, 72 kg schwer und 1,68 m groß.
Bei uns hat sich die Patientin seit 3 Tagen plötzlich aufgetretener, wellinformiger, stehender Schmerzen in die linke Seite,
wo sind die Schmerzen?
Die Prypogastrium.
Unterbau?
Unterbau, okay.
Im Begriff?
Im Unterbau.
Rechts, links haben Sie gesagt.
Die Schmerzen seien im Laufe der Seite starker geworden und der Patientin zufolge liegt die Schmerzintensität auf einer Schmerzsikrade bei 6 und 7.
Und dagegen haben die Patienten heute Morgen 2-mal Parasitamol eingenommen und dass die Schmerzen ein bisschen verbessert haben.
Und die Patienten finden hin, sodass die Schmerzen in die Leisten ausstrahlen würden.
Und sie leiden unter Übel, aber haben sie keine Erbräuche.
Die Frage nach IBA, nach Schweiß, Gewichtsveränderung wurden verneins.
Und bei der Bewegung haben die Schmerzen sich verschlechtert.
Die Patientin sagte, dass beim Wasserlassen und beim Stuhlgang die Patienten sagt, dass beim Wasserlassen und Stuhlgang treten Schmerzen auf.
Was bedeutet das?
Schmerzloß.
Algüri.
Es gab keine Brennen.
Die Schmerzen am Unterbauch werden mehr.
Beim Wasserlassen, Schmerzhaft bei Masbelassen.
Das Wasserlassen ist nicht schmerzhaft, sondern wenn beim Wasserlassen die Schmerzen im Unterbauch werden mehr.
Nicht das in der Hand rüber.
Keine.
Nein.
Schmerzprobleme?
Nein, habe ich noch gesagt.
Während der Stuhlgang Schmerzen am linken Unterbauch.
Okay.
Die Patientin ist vollständig geimpft und treibt nicht keinen Sport.
Sie ist allergisch gegen Polen.
Die allergische Reaktion äußere sich mit laufenden Nasen und Augen brennen.
Bei Bedarf nehmen sie Scythesin ein.
Sie ist außerdem unverträglich gegenüber Laktose.
Sehr gut.
An der Vorerkrankung leiden sie seit zwei Jahren Arturiela Hipertoni.
Und dagegen nehmen sie Kandesatan 4 mg einmal.
Und noch etwas.
In der Familie einem Nasen fanden sie sich an eine unbestimmte oder unklare Frustraterkrankung bei dem Vater.
Und dann wurde der Vater eine fankre Prostata-Operation durchgeführt.
Die Mutter ist gesund. Sie arbeitet als Frösöserin.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei Kinder.
Und sie liebt mit ihrem Mann zusammen.
Die an den nöstischen Angaben deuten am Ehesten auf Handrankentzündung oder auf Hin- oder auf keine Pärzdiagnose.
Die Patientin hat doch etwas.
Oder ihr leuchtet es vielleicht.
Sie muss eine Arbeitsdiagnose nehmen und dann ihren Differenzialdiagnosen aufzählen.
Was ist Ihre Arbeitsdiagnose oder Verdachtdiagnose?
Meine Pärzdiagnose ist Storader Ballang.
Einmal gesagt, die Vertribulität ist nirgisch.
Ja, das ist das.
Ich gehe von Vertribulität aus als Verdachtdiagnose aus.
Alternative Common, zum Beispiel Leuhaus.
Handrankentzündung.
Was für eine Entzündung?
Handrank.
Handrankentzündung gibt es nicht.
Ja.
Handleiter.
Okay, Handleiter.
Handleiterentzündung gibt es auch nicht. Es gibt Handleiterstein.
Handleiterstein.
Ja.
Oder ein Handwegsinfekt.
Und Entzündung bei Handwege.
Entzündung der Handwege, genau.
Da kommen einige Tipps.
Aha, okay.
Vielleicht Renalkolik.
Was für eine Kolik?
Renalkolik.
Ich habe das nicht verstanden. Akustisch?
Neerenkolik.
Okay, was kommt noch in Frage?
Die Kollegen haben schon geholfen?
Ja, eine Kollegin hat geschrieben.
Eine Transparenzdiagnose.
Extra-Utterengravity, ist das möglich?
Eine Möglichkeit, eine extra-uterine Gravidität.
Eine Artnexitis.
Artnexitis, eine Artnexitis.
Entzündung.
Ja, genau.
Woran muss man noch denken?
Ich hatte heute Morgen einen Patienten, der hat wahrscheinlich einen Leistenbruch.
Eine inkarzerierte Leistenbrüche.
Eine inkarzerierte Leistenbrüche links.
Ja.
Es gibt keine Vorwürbung, aber ich habe schon gefragt.
Ja, aber muss nicht.
Ja.
Das ist eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Inkarzerierte, das heißt keine Fieber.
Das ist keine große Schwellung, meistens hat man ganz wenig oder gar keine Schwellung.
Auf Deutsch, ich glaube, eingeklemmte Leistenbrüche.
Ja, eingeklemmte Leistenbrüche, richtig.
Ja, so weiter.
Haben wir, Hanleiterstein, haben wir gesagt, ja?
Okay.
Und so weiter in Abklärung, würde ich gerne körperliche Untersuchungen
und Blutabnahmen,
ja, IPG und Blutwerten, zum Beispiel,
klassisch Blutbild, Blutzucker,
CRP und Nierenwerte
durchführen.
Und auch, ich möchte gerne,
Utrechtal und Blutgernaufnahme
veranlassen und durchführen.
Und, ja, sehr gut.
Also der Patient oder die Patientin hat wahrscheinlich,
das war heute Morgen eine Prämie in der Praxis,
eine inkarzerierte Leistenherne wahrscheinlich.
Inkarzer.
Aber eine eingeklemmte Leistenherne.
Aber natürlich, die Differenzialdiagnose von Diverticulitis,
wie es sehr nahe liegend kann sein,
Hanleiterstein kann sowas machen.
Und natürlich die chronische entzündlichen Datenbekrankungen,
Morbuschron, Qualitis ulcerosa,
auch daran muss man denken.
Eine Tumorerkrankung, eine Sigma-Karzinom
kann man sowas machen.
Eine Gastroenteritis,
eine ganz stinknormale Magen-Damen-Entzündung,
Durchfall, wobei dieser Patientin hat jetzt keinen Durchfall.
Aber auch an sowas muss man denken.
Wenn die Jungen viel Luft an solche Schmerzen machen.
Und was haben wir vergessen?
Eine Lumbargie,
wo man solche Schmerzen auslösen.
Und dann eine Hanblasenentzündung,
natürlich eine Cystitis kann sowas machen.
Eine extra oterine Schwangerschaft,
eine Eileiterentzündung,
eine Endometriose,
so was muss man mal denken bei Frauen.
Du siehst, jünger Mann, es gibt viele Differenzialdiagnosen.
Okay.
Was sind Sie für Fahrarzt?
Ach so, nee.
Ich habe nur einen Durchfall, sonst habe ich nur noch einen Arbeitsplatz.
Alles, sonst als danach.
Ich habe noch keine Erfahrung.
Dann kommt es noch nicht her.
Sehr gut, wunderbar.
Haben die Kollegen oder die Kolleginnen noch Fragen?
Noch nicht?
Nein, ich bin heute Abend in der Schule.
Ich bin ein bisschen müde.
Es war ein sehr langer Tag.
Ich hoffe, dass es trotzdem effektiv war.
Wie die